what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 breakdown video season 7 episode 2
just ended so let's discuss everything
that went down the episode starts off at
Dragonstone during a thunderstorm which
is a nice callback to the name of this
episode which is also one of the
nicknames Daenerys Targaryen has this
episode was titled Stormborn Daenerys
Targaryen was born on Dragonstone during
a very bad storm and now that she's back
in Westeros and back on Dragonstone
she's about to bring a storm of her own
we go inside the nearest Targaryen swore
room where she is having a meeting with
Tyrion gray were missandei and Varys the
theme of the conversation they're having
is serving Daenerys puts Varys is
serving into question Varys used to work
for the Mad King which is Danny's father
but after the Mad King was murdered by
Jaime Lannister Varys started working
for Robert Baratheon the same man who
killed Daenerys his brother during the
battle at the Trident Daenerys also
knows that Varys played a role in her
assassination attempt all the way back
in season 1 when the wine merchant tried
to serve Daenerys poisoned wine Daenerys
questions whether she can now trust
Varys or not and Varys talks about how
he doesn't serve any king or queen he
serves the people he serves the realm
but Varys says if Daenerys lets him live
he will serve her well but Daenerys
reminds him that if he ever betrays her
she will burn him alive with her dragons
fire Daenerys also tells Varys that if
she ever starts to fade as a ruler he
better tell her before he makes any
decisions of his own it's interesting
that Daenerys already has this in her
mind because she knows that the road
ahead as a ruler is not going to be an
easy one to travel I wasn't sure what
Daenerys would ever do to Varys when she
found out he helped with the
assassination attempt I did expect a
little more punishment than he got but
she does need good counsel right now
since Jorah and Selmy are gone Varys may
have a checkered past but he could come
in the youth stow in the future grey
worm then tells the nurse that
Melisandre is there and she wants to
speak with her once again serving
becomes the topic of the conversation
Varys reminds Melisandre that she once
served Stannis and we all know how that
ended up which should make Daenerys
question whether she wants mellow song
Halperin on but Melisandre warns
Daenerys and tells her the long night is
coming
she says John is the prince that was
promised and he will be the one to bring
dawn by ending the long night but my
Sande says something interesting right
here that may come into play at a later
date
missandei says that the noun has no
gender meaning the prophecy could mean
it's the prince or princess that was
promised this is a cool reference
because this also has something to do
with the valonqar prophecy when Cersei
met with Maggie the Frog she told Cersei
that the valonqar will wrap his hands
around her pale white throat and choke
the life from her most of us already
knew the valonqar is a Valyrian word and
it was gender-neutral
but now it's show Kanan too because
missandei made the reference about the
prince that was promised prophecy so
this might be something to keep note of
but let's move on
Melisandre tells Daenerys that she has a
role to play also Daenerys and Jon will
need to unite in order to end the long
night and I got his mitt I like that
Melisandre still stands behind Jon Snow
even though he did banish her from the
north
I'm glad Melisandre didn't flip-flop and
say Daenerys is the savior now in
Daenerys only but what I like even more
is what happened next
Tyrion stands behind Jon as well back in
season 1 episode 1 Tyrion and Jon met
outside a Winterfell while John was
blowing off some steam because lady
Catelyn made him go outside because she
didn't want him to upset the guests
because he was a bastard and Tyrion gave
him some wise advice he tells him to
wear it like armor so that it can never
be used against him to hurt him this was
the beginning of the relationship jon
was a bit standoffish at first but as
they spend time together going to the
wall and being at the wall together they
did grow a lot closer and Jon began to
respect Tyrion also he knew Tyrion
wasn't like any of the other Lannisters
there was something special about him
when Tyrion decided he was going to
leave the wall to head back south him
and Jon shook hands and wished each
other farewell and I always knew Tyrion
would come back into Jon's life at some
point and these two together will play a
big role in the end game the cripples
bastards and broken things will all come
together and be the ones to end this
long night it won't only be the prince
that was promised it's going to take a
group effort but Tyrion tells Daenerys
that he trusts
Jon Snow and he's an excellent judge of
character Daenerys does agree to meet
with John but she wants him to bend the
knee as well as much time as John spent
with the wildlings he may not want to
bend the knee but I think John will do
whatever it takes to help his people and
basically all the people in the realm
John might end up being another king who
know just like tauren stark did when
Aegon came to Westeros which is kind of
crazy because John has Aegon in thorns
blood in his veins
but speaking of John snow that's where
we go next in Winterfell training has
already begun Jon told everyone in
episode 1 that he was going to need men
women and children prepared to fight
when the night King comes john has
already received a raven from Tyrion
which to letter reminds John of the
quote Tyrion said to him when they first
met all dwarves are bastards in their
father's eyes Jon lake's Tyrion and he
trusts him enough to go meet with him
and although sons agrees that Tyrion was
a good man she knows it's risky for Jon
to go himself but Jon knows that if he
doesn't form this alliance soon Cersei
will stay on the throne and run the
kingdom right into the ground
Jon knows they can end her tyranny
together plus he really needs Danny's
help when the long night sets of a
Westeros
if the dead get past the wall Jon will
not have enough men on his own to stop
them but with Daenerys and her army and
dragons they can at least give the
[ __ ] a fight and Davos makes an even
better point goddess remembers that Jon
said fire can kill White's
and what Danny's dragons they can kill a
shitload of whites at one time
Davos may be a little cautious inside as
well but he will stand beside Jon's
decision he knows what's coming
and he believes Jon and together they
can make the right choices for the
people next we go down in King's Landing
where Cersei is having a discussion
about Daenerys as well Cersei is
spreading propaganda in her favour about
Daenerys she warns the Lords that
Daenerys will be just like her father
she will feed people to her dragons and
she has the Dothraki with her who are
absolute savages this is something
Robert Baratheon was always worried
about
he warned Ned and Cersei that if the
death wreck he ever made it to Westeros
they would be in some serious trouble
and Cersei knows this she will do or say
anything she can to stop them Cersei has
no plans of stepping down off the throne
and handing it
/ - a Targaryen what I loved about this
scene was what Qyburn had to say he's
already been hard at work making a
device to stop the Dragons and I believe
with this device they will kill at least
one dragon it seemed like Daenerys would
be unstoppable
but now that Cersei is gaining allies
and has an anti dragon weapon you can
see the playing field starting to even
out a bit which should make for the wars
to come very exciting
Sam Charlie's father and brother are
here meeting with Cersei as well the
tarly's are house Tyrell is most loyal
bannermen right now and randyll Tarly is
one of the greatest battle commanders in
history so this would make for one hell
of an alliance for Cersei but Randall
isn't so quick to turn sides just yet
but Jaime speaks to him privately and
gives him an offer he may reconsider
Jamie says Cersei is going to need a new
warden of the south once Lady Olenna is
defeated and this would be a nice
promotion for randyll Tarly but what
would be enough to get him to go onto
their side in betray House Tyrell but
before Jamie makes this offer
Randall gives Jaime a nice jab by saying
he's not an Oathbreaker or a backstabber
what's Jaime literally is since he
stabbed the Mad King in the back
although randyll Tarly said this you
should expect to see him fighting for
the Lannisters in the future next scene
we go down Old Town where Jorah Mormont
is being looked over by Samuel totally
in the archmaester gorge maester tells
Jorah he should have cut his arm off
immediately
but now it's too late he might live for
a few more years but within six months
jor is going to start to lose his mind
just like the stone men that attacked
him and Tyrion fortunately for Jorah he
isn't just an average Joe because if he
was the Auris maester said he would have
been shipped off the Valyria where all
the other stone men are but since he
comes from a respected family in Jorah
is well known throughout the Seven
Kingdoms they won't stick a boot in his
ass just yet but there is nothing they
can do to save him his greyscale was too
far gone at this point and Jorah does
look pretty damn bad his entire arm and
abdomen is covered in it now but sam
wants to help anyway sam spent time with
Stannis and his daughter at the wall and
he knows princess Shireen had her
greyscale stopped from spreading and
killing her Sam knows that something can
be done to save Jorah and when Sam hears
Joris
his name is Mormont he immediately makes
the connection to his father G or
Mormont who was Sam's Lord Commander
while he was at the Nights Watch Sam is
going to risk his life in career to help
Jorah in any way that he can we then go
back to King's Landing where Qyburn
takes Cersei downstairs where all the
dragon skulls are which is the same
place arya hid when she heard Varys and
Ilario talking about the wolf and the
lying being at war with each other
Qyburn reveals what he has been working
on his anti dragon weapon and it works
beautifully he puts an arrow right
through the skull of balerion the black
dread Aegon Targaryen is biggest dragon
balerion was much bigger than drug on
and after seeing the arrow ripped right
through his skull it's going to have no
problem taking down one of the nurses
dragons things are getting very exciting
now
Cersei just leveled up once again one of
those arrows through the dragon's eye
and it's over for it one of the fastest
ways to kill a dragon is piercing its
eye but it's not going to be easy to hit
a moving target back on Dragonstone
Daenerys has a big meeting with all of
her new alliances Yara suggests that
they hit King's Landing now and they hit
it hard in the city will fall but give
antarians character on the show we all
knew he wouldn't want this to happen
right away not only because he doesn't
want to kill all the people but he wants
to save his brother Jaime from being
killed as well this is kind of
interesting because during Tyrians trial
he said he wanted to give everyone
poison but I'm guessing he just meant
two people in the courtroom that day and
not all of the citizens in King's
Landing Tyrion does confront a Lauria
though he does know a Lori had killed
his niece Marcella now I know Tyrion has
allies with the same snakes but I was
expecting him to be a little more harsh
in this scene it was forgotten pretty
quickly it seemed Tyrion hate Cersei but
he did not hate Marcella but my favorite
thing about this scene was how they set
the stage for the upcoming Wars
Daenerys wants to cut off Circe's food
supply and surround her inside King's
Landing leaving her with nowhere to go
since she doesn't want to destroy the
city this was the next best move in my
opinion Jorah and Ilario will go get all
the troops from Dorne then worked her
way back up to King's Landing the
unsullied will attack Casterly Rock
cutting off the Lannisters secondary
troops and Circe's only other place to
bunker down besides King's Landing
then she will have the Dornishmen and
Tyrell army lay siege to King's Landing
Daenerys promises that Cersei will pay
but Alanna reminds her that peace never
lasts and although Tyrion is a clever
man she should ignore him Elena says she
is a dragon and she should be a dragon
Elena doesn't want to play games she
wants Cersei snuffed out immediately but
then we go to a lovemaking session with
missandei and grey worm and there's not
a whole lot to say here other than they
want to build up this romance in the
show only so they can kill one of them
off later and make it more emotional one
of these characters will die very soon I
think and personally I think it's going
to be grey worm I got to be honest
though at first I thought grey worm
might still have his pillar but when he
went down on the same day it pretty much
confirmed that he does not which totally
sucks for grey worm but hey he made the
best of the situation we then go back to
old town where it's obvious Sam is very
anxious to talk about Jorah in his
greyscale Sam is eager to discuss it
because he knows he can help jor-el and
he wants to help him but the arch
maester says it's forbidden because
Jorah is too far gone now but Sam risks
his life and career anyway just like the
description of this episode said he
would we go to jours room where he's
writing a letter to Khaleesi but Sam
comes in ready to get to work and I
thought this scene was kind of funny
because Sam tells Jorah to drink some
rum to ease the pain but sam takes a big
swig of it too because he's nervous as
hell and I don't care how much rum Jorah
drinks that [ __ ] would hurt like hell
and there is no way he doesn't scream or
at least pass out from the pain
Sam starts peeling the greyscale off
that's covering his entire midsection
this would take a very long time and be
painful as hell but I believe in hope
Sam will get them fixed up pretty
quickly so drawer can come back into the
plot and get with Jon and go up north
and kick some white Walker ass next we
see Arya at the end on the crossroads
and we get our first reunion with Arya
and Hawkeye but I got to be honest this
reunion was a bit anticlimactic Arya
wasn't very excited to see him I was
kind of expecting a big hug but the
conversation they have is more important
than that thanks to Hawkeye we now know
rumors have spread that Cersei blew up
the Sept she might have some people
fooled up in King's Landing but she
doesn't have everyone fooled
and Aria lets it be known that she's
heading there to King's Landing for
Cersei but hot pie drops a bombshell on
Aria and tells her the Bolton's have
been defeated and John now has
Winterfell back under the stark banner
this was really cool this is what
changes arias course of direction since
John has Winterfell she decides to go
home although I know John is about to
leave for the south this did make me
very happy
Aria and John have a very good
relationship together and you can tell
she really wants to see him right away
John gave Aria her sword needle back in
season 1 and when Aria needed to give up
her identity to become a faceless man
needle was the one thing she wasn't
willing to completely let go of because
she truly loves John as her brother and
I can't wait for this reunion back in
Winterfell
John has received another raven but this
time from Sam a very important letter I
must say Sam tells John about the dragon
glass down on Dragonstone and John lets
it be known to everyone that he trusts
Sam and he knows he must go right away
to prepare the defenses against the
night king but all the other northerners
aren't too accepting of the help from a
Targaryen Songza reminds John that her
father the Mad King murdered their
family and once again John has to make
the tough decision that might make him
look bad now but it will help humanity
in the long run no one else is thinking
as far ahead as John is he's the only
one willing to do whatever it takes to
stop the true threat beyond the wall
John didn't want to become king but he
accepted it because the north is his
home and he will do whatever he thinks
is best to protect it but songs it
thinks it's a trap John tells awnser
that he must go and he's going to leave
her in charge of Winterfell while he is
gone and I thought this was pretty
interesting because when John said this
song says shut up pretty damn quick she
almost had a look in her eye like she
enjoyed the small taste of power once
John said that she agreed with them
right away
and this could be a small sign of
something to come in the future while
John is gone John then goes down into
the crypts to visit with family before
he leaves and Littlefinger comes down
and then erupts him and he just doesn't
shut up almost as if Littlefinger was
purposely trying to push John's buttons
Littlefinger had the nerve to say he was
sorry when that died although we all
know Littlefinger was the one who helped
put net in that damn position he even
reminds John that lady Catelyn
didn't love him I mean what the [ __ ]
little finger are you trying to get
yourself killed he also wants John to
thank him for helping him during the
Battle of the bastards
but then he crosses the line
Littlefinger says he loves Songza and
cat and John grabs him by the throat and
slams him against the wall and he tells
him if he touches Songza he will kill
him himself and I absolutely loved that
it just felt so good to see Littlefinger
grab by his throat again and threatened
to be killed once again I just can't
wait for it to actually happen but
something interesting happens next one
little finger comes out of the crypts he
sees songs outside on the walkway and
his shady ass theme music begins to play
as he looks at Sansa you already know
once John leaves Littlefinger will get
right back to work on Sansa putting a
wedge between her and John even more
Littlefinger is going to try and snatch
the north right out of John's hands
let's just hope so as it stays woke long
enough to see him coming for it next we
see Arya starting a fire as she takes a
break from traveling home this was one
of my favorite scenes from the episode
as Arya is building her fire the horse
begins to get startled when it hears
something moving around in the woods
that's when Arya draws Nita one begins
to scan the treeline looking to see
what's out there and all of a sudden she
is surrounding by about 10 wolves and
she's frightened thinking she's about to
be attacked at all sides but then we get
the money shot ladies and gentlemen
something we've all been waiting for
since season 1 episode 2 Nymeria emerges
from the woods and all the other wolves
immediately start to back down and this
was absolutely beautiful I really like
this scene arya recognizes its Nymeria
and she tells her she is going home back
to Winterfell
Arya once Nymeria to come with her and
deep down I really wanted her to go with
her too but the way this scene ended was
completely understandable in my opinion
Nymeria goes back into the treeline and
already knows she will not be coming
alone and this makes Arya very emotional
at first but then Oriya realizes why she
isn't going to come and Arya says that's
not you that was the same thing Arya
said to her father when that said Arya
would become a lady and have children of
her own
Arya told her father That's not me and
Arya knows that's not her diary with
either
Nymeria is wild now
and can't be tamed and settled down in
one location just like aurilla has been
the way they seen and did made a lot of
sense I thought I would love for Nymeria
to be at Aria side but Nymeria must run
with their pack which I completely
understand and last but not least we get
our final scene of the episode the sand
snakes in the Ironborn are together
traveling down to Dorne to get more
troops just like Daenerys had planned
you're in the sand snakes are doing a
little unwinding as they discuss who
gets to kill the mountain they talk
about Dorne Yara talks about going both
ways and a Lauria asks Theon for a drink
and Yara lets it be known that Theon
isn't any one servant but he will be
yours protector and this is when we get
a little girl-on-girl action but not
much because you're on Greyjoy shows up
the crash to party you're on slams his
ship silence right into the ship and he
had a claw on the front of his ship that
he dropped down to sink its teeth in the
third so their ship couldn't escape it
was actually pretty damn cool and then
it's party time the battle won the sea
begins and you're on isn't [ __ ]
around he looks like a damn maniac and I
absolutely loved it
tyene starts dropping people with her
blade and she's very accurate with that
damn thing but your screams out that
ilaria needs to be safe but it's already
too late the Ironborn or everywhere I
thought it was interesting that ilaria
asked for death she knows she's not
going to be treated too kindly no matter
who takes her prisoner and I'm surprised
she didn't have some poison handy to
just take herself out but I guess they
need her to be a prisoner so she didn't
have it at this time although she always
does we then go back up to the top deck
where you're on kills one of the sand
snakes real quick and Yara enters the
fight and tackles you're onto the ground
but she rolls off him and ends up
getting a blade put to her throat Theon
witnesses all of this and you're on
dares him to try and stop him and save
his sister but Theon is still
shell-shocked after what Ramsay did to
him for years he has severe PTSD and as
he looks around at the carnage he
freezes up there is nothing he can do at
this point but mark my words
Theon will be given a second chance he
will get another crack at your own this
won't be the last time these two Greyjoy
see each other next time
Theon better bring his a-game and snap
out of that [ __ ] because I have always
felt feel and will complete his
character or bite
killing his uncle and I really hope he
does but unfortunately for now Theon
regressed back into his recharacterize
umph Soph the ship to save himself Yara
ilaria in tyene are taken away his
prisoners and will now become Circe's
new gift and at the mercy of Circe in
the mountain as silent sails away Theon
watches from the water knowing that his
sister is doomed and only time will tell
if Theon will be able to redeem himself
before it's too late in the episode ends
this episode did pick up the pace a
little bit there were definitely some
better moments in this one than the
first one
I liked this episode a lot better it was
nice to finally see your own in action
and fully embrace his character some
more there was also an awesome callback
to the books during this scene there
were bodies strung up to the front of
the ship which is something Euron has
done before in the books that was cool
to see that they added that in there I
also loved a quick scene of Aria and I
marry it together although it was
short-lived but at least we got a little
bit more closure on that and we may see
her again depending how things play out
also with mother Sondra being on
Dragonstone with Daenerys it adds a nice
little extra layer to her story that
should get very interesting very soon
most likely in the next episode when
John arrives so what did you all think
about this episode was there stuff you
loved or liked or was there stuff you
didn't like or hated let me know what
you thought about everything on this one
as always thanks for stopping by and
checking out the video I hope everyone
enjoyed it and a big thanks to my
patreon supporters for always showing
love I'll see you all down in the
comment section bye